In recent years, some of the world's biggest companies...
...have discarded depth and detail to debrand.
Burger King lost weight.
Rolling Stone found a cleaner edge.
VW shed its depth and shadow,...
...as did Kia, Pfizer, Nissan, Durex, Intel, Toyota...
...and a host of other major brands.
Even the munchable hero Julius Pringle had a flattening make-under...
...with shaved head, dyed mustache, dilated eyes and new pre-strung eyebrows.
But what prompted this landslide of logo debranding?
Several interlocking forces are at work,...
...the most immediate of which is the pressure of mobile first design.
Clients used to ask, "Can you make the logo bigger?"
Now the trick is to shrink an entire identity into a tiny digital box.
Such pixel pressure usually means returning to the 2D look of old.
Of course, this 2D look was more or less the norm until computers took over...
...and design inflation spiraled out of control.
Anyone who has overfiltered an Instagram sunset...
...knows the seductive lure of visual excess,...
...and it's a seduction to which the pros are not immune.
The ability to round corners, drop shadows, customize gradients...
...and create complex lighting effects can easily overpower the creative brief...
...and often does.
So many recently brands represent a return to sobriety...
...after a spasm of software-embedded intoxication.